in an unprecedented power grab the
democrat-run house of representatives
has voted
to strip a republican congressman of
her committee seats they did this
ostensibly because the republican
congressman
has said kooky things on social media in
the past
in reality this is just a power grab you
want to talk about upsetting
historical and political norms this is
something we really haven't seen before
and of course if the reasoning is
legitimate if
delusion is disqualifying for serving in
congress
then we're not just going to have to
remove one person from committees we're
going to have to abolish all the
committees
we're probably going to have to abolish
the entire house of representatives
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from julio rosa
who says aoc is the kind of girl that
wears red to a stranger's funeral
and cries louder than the actual family
of the deceased
this is true she also might stage some
photo ops there she might not actually
be at the funeral but just sort of just
out
outside the frame and she'd be posing
crying
actually we'll have a little bit of aoc
and crying and posing
just a little bit later in the show but
it's not time for that right now how do
i know it
because of my movement watch valentine's
day is right around the corner and this
is your ticket to win big beautiful
packaging
super sleek designs lasting classic
gifts
much better than flowers if you're
single you know that it is time to treat
yourself
you know what you like best so take
advantage of the sale right now
take a look through movements hundreds
of styles to choose from i have been
wearing movement watches
for years uh they've got every
every sort of watch you might want you
got those these kind of minimalist
more modern designs they've got some
more
sort of detailed automatic watches even
i love their automatic watch
check them out they've got the quality
of a 400 500 watching get them a whole
lot cheaper
i've loved watches since i was eight
years old and i've really really enjoyed
movement watches use code the day 20 at
checkout to save 20
off on the perfect gif mvmt
dot com slash knowles mvmt.com you will
get
free shipping and free returns you can
join the movement
go to mvmt.coms a great valentine's day
gift
that by the way won't break the bank and
really really great quality
code v-day 20 for 20 off make sure you
go check out movement
gotta love them they've been with the
show from the very beginning
go check out movement
i do not go for conspiracy theories
generally speaking now what makes a
conspiracy theory i guess we could
debate that all day long
but i'm i'm not tempted to believe in
conspiracy theories i usually try to go
for the simplest answer to things
i i believe that so many people would
need to be
involved and on the know and know how to
keep a secret for some of these theories
to be true that i just don't buy it
however i always enjoy reading
conspiracy theories i really like it
i will go down internet rabbit holes on
all the craziest sort of conspiracy
theories
not because i think they're plausible
but because i
i enjoy seeing the thinking that goes
into them
i have always gone sort of light on
friends of mine who come to me with kind
of crazy conspiracy theories
i don't harangue them i don't scream at
them i don't castigate them because
i i find them in a way sometimes
delightful uh conspiracies and
conspiracy theories can be the sign
of an active mind might be the sign of a
deranged mind but
at least active at least people are
thinking about these things
the other the other reason that i don't
harang and go after people
who push these conspiracy theories is
every once in a while maybe not one out
of ten times maybe not one out of 100
maybe it's one in a million
but every once in a while they turn out
to be true
we've talked a lot about conspiracy
theories with regard to the
2020 election and if you if you even
suggest
that anything was awry anything was
irregular about the election
you could be d platforms you could be
kicked off of the internet
you could be kicked off of your servers
you could be kicked
off of all these sorts of things but
sometimes
turns out that they're true for instance
time magazine publishes
the secret history of the shadow
campaign
that saved the 2020 election this is a
very
very long article i killed many trees
printing out this article
obviously i'm not going to read anywhere
near the whole thing but just just a few
a few important paragraphs i think here
the the article opens up talking about
how trump had all these theories that
the election was going to be rigged and
then
and then she writes in a way
trump was right there was a conspiracy
unfolding behind the scenes
one that both curtailed the protests and
coordinated the resistance from ceos
both surprises were the result of an
informal alliance between left-wing
activists
and business titans the pact was
formalized in a terse little notice
joint statement of the u.s chamber of
commerce
and the afl-cio published on election
day this was
an agreement that they basically were
not going to pursue claims of
voter fraud skip a bit their work
this this informal alliance their work
touched
every aspect of the election so
so this is not just after election day
but even before the election you had
this
this alliance of all these these various
groups time magazine right i'm not
reading some
crazy message board on the internet
their work touched
every aspect of the election they got
states to change
voting systems and laws and helped
secure hundreds of millions in public
and private funding
they fended off voter suppression
lawsuits also known as voter integrity
lawsuits
recruited armies of poll workers and got
millions of people to vote by mail for
the first time
some of them i think voted for the first
time because they died in 1892.
they successfully pressured social media
companies to take a harder line against
disinformation
uh that that is code word for they
pressured big tech oligarchs to
censor conservatives and used
data-driven strategies to fight viral
smears
like for instance when the new york post
got the story on hunter biden's
corruption in ukraine and china
and they published it and it taught they
tied it possibly
potentially to joe biden and then big
tech
suppressed the article you couldn't even
private message it to somebody on
twitter
you know those data-driven strategies
they executed national public awareness
campaigns
that helped americans understand how the
vote count would unfold over days or
weeks
preventing trump's conspiracy theories
and false claims of victory from getting
traction
that's code word for they primed
everybody
for to always doubt any republican win
because they said that if a republican
won on election day
sure that might happen but it would be a
red mirage and don't worry because once
they finish counting the votes
three weeks later in philly don't worry
it's going to be fine the democrats are
going to turn out to win
so they already prepped using big tech
they already prepped everybody
not to trust any republican victory
after election day they monitor
every pressure point to ensure that
trump could not overturn the result
every pressure point what's that
that's the courts that's the election
officials that's public opinion
the untold story of the election is the
thousands of people of both parties who
accomplished the triumph
of american democracy at its very
foundation
says norm eisen a prominent lawyer and
former obama official
who recruited republicans and democrats
to the board of the voter protection
program this this is the key here to me
i mean we could go on there are many
more thousands of words in this article
everything that has been described thus
far is a way to subvert
american democracy they're going to
upend all the voter laws
they're going to get big tech oligarchs
to clamp down on free speech
they're going to suppress stories that
are damaging to democrats
they're going to stop election lawsuits
after the fact
they're going to take away other ballot
integrity measures
and this is the triumph of american
democracy at its very foundation
the way that a democrat an obama
official can say this with a straight
face
is because of something that we've
talked about a lot on this show
four democrats according to democrats
democracy is what happens when they win
elections
because of progress because we know
where we're headed we know the arc of
history we know the science of politics
because we know what's in everybody's
interest
if they only throw off their shackles
because we know that democrats are
always supposed to win
and republicans cannot win it is
illegitimate for them to win they're all
nazis
75 million nazis running around the
country because of that
any time a republican does win it has to
be
illegitimate it has to be through fraud
it has to be because of russia
or the macedonian click farms or ukraine
or whatever right it can't be
legit so
if you undermine all of the democratic
principles of our country if you if you
undermine the institutions and
the policies that are in place to
protect the vote but you do it in order
to defeat a republican and help elect a
democrat
that is seriously in their mind the
triumph
of democracy absolutely
absolutely outrageous stuff there are
two republican responses
to this sort of thing you can either be
really upset or you can be really happy
and there are some republicans who are
really happy namely
wyoming congressman liz cheney daughter
of dick cheney
liz cheney uh hated trump has always
hated trump
voted to impeach trump the second time
over nothing is a completely farcical
vote now liz cheney who has just managed
to hold on to her
minor leadership position in the house
gop caucus threw a secret ballot she
wouldn't have kept it otherwise
liz cheney is is going on the offensive
against trump she's saying
that trump has no role in the future of
the republican party
chris we're the party of abraham lincoln
we're the party of ronald reagan
we have to really take a hard look at
who we are and what we stand for what we
believe in
i think it when you look at both uh his
actions leading up to what happened on
january 6th
the fact that he was impeached in a
bipartisan fashion
the fact that that he lost the
presidency the fact that we lost the
senate
we have to be in a position where we can
say we stand for principles we stand for
ideals
uh somebody who has provoked an attack
on the united states capital to prevent
the counting of electoral votes
which resulted in five people dying who
refused
to stand up immediately when he was
asked and stopped the violence
that that is a person who does not have
a role as a leader of our party going
forward we have to make sure
that we are able to convey to the
american voters we
are the party of responsibility we are
the party of truth
uh that we actually can be trusted to
handle the challenges this nation faces
like covid
and and that's going to require us to
focus on substance and policy and issues
going forward but but we should not be
embracing the former president it's
difficult for me to take liz cheney
seriously when she says we should be the
party of truth
as she is saying so many things that are
untrue she's saying that president trump
provoked an attack on the capital
now he clearly said be peaceful don't be
violent be peaceful
before the attack the whole time you
might say well because he was
questioning the election because he had
these lawsuits because he was saying all
these things
that in itself provoked the attack okay
but then she says he refused to condemn
the violence he condemned the violence
before during and after the riot at the
capitol so that's just not true
she says we need to have these clear
ideals and principles i got to tell you
something
i've lived through you know few admin
republican administrations now
the only republican administration that
i heard anything resembling clear
principles from
was trump i got a lot of mixed stuff
from the bush cheney administration
a lot of going back on certain campaign
promises we're not going to nation build
we're going to do this we're going to do
that
passing massive massive entitlement
programs after they said they'd govern
as conservatives
even going back to bush's father read my
lips no new taxes how did that turn out
major promise completely broken so i
just don't want to hear the sanctimony
anymore
but but some republicans believe the
first thing we have to do priority
number one
attack republicans and in particular
attack
the most recent republican president
it's it's very frustrating that they do
this to trump
because to me trump is is like
everything he touched compared to other
politicians
more or less turned to gold and if you
want to invest in gold you got to check
out
acre gold how is that segway man
got to savor that for a second you know
how the price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately well now there's a
new way to buy gold through a company
called
acre acre lets you subscribe to gold
bars for as little as
thirty dollars a month how on earth does
that work gold bars cost more than
thirty dollars well
it's an ingenious strategy you pay each
month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your house
just recently acre has introduced a new
100 a month subscription to a 5 gram
gold bar
also check this out you know how there's
a nationwide shortage on ammo right now
well acres crafting this is so cool a
solid gold
24 karat gold nine millimeter bullet you
can buy it
now now you cannot find anything like
these on the internet they are only
making 1 000 of them
so they're going fast to be clear i
can't believe i have to clear this up
uh you can't shoot these bullets right i
guess unless you're trying to kill a
werewolf or something
uh they're they're really really cool go
check them out visit getacre gold.com
michael start investing in physical gold
today make sure you go to this url
because acre is giving away a gold
bar to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is get acre gold.com
michael thank you aker gold for
supporting the show do you know how much
i've loved investing in precious metals
go check it out at acre gold
so there's two ways to respond to
the constant and increasing democratic
attacks
and exaggerations and lies
one is you can buy into all of them you
can encourage them even
you can attack republicans first you can
attack your own guys first that's
a typical response then there's another
response
which is realize that it's a completely
bad faith debate
realize that the democrats are being
disingenuous in their attacks
realize that everything they accuse us
of doing they've done 10 times over
and actually fight back against our
real political opponents the democrats
and not just encourage infighting among
amongst ourselves
rand paul gets this rand paul was asked
about all of these sorts of
uh attacks on republicans and he he
decided to go on the offensive
you know i opposed the notion of which i
think was a misguided notion of voting
to overturn the election
either with congress or with the vice
president but i think if we're going to
criminalize speech
and somehow impeach everybody who says
oh go fight to hear your voices heard
i mean really we ought to impeach chuck
schumer then he went to the supreme
court
stood in front of the supreme court and
said specifically hey gorsuch hey
kavanagh
you've unleashed a whirlwind and you're
going to pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you
continue with these awful decisions
this inflammatory wording this violent
rhetoric retraction
was so bad the chief justice who rarely
says anything publicly
immediately said this kind of language
is dangerous
as a mob tried to invade the supreme
court so if people want to call hold
president trump accountable for language
there has to be a consistent standard
and to my mind it's a partisan farce
because they're not doing anything to
chuck schumer
not doing anything to representative
omar not doing anything to maxine waters
it's just not fair it's just partisan
politics under a different name
thank you thank you rand rand paul has
really been impressing me of late
he is here speaking specifically about
the impeachment
this could could be said though of of
many other political
matters today the question of kicking
people off of committees or
banishing trump you know from the
republican party
it's a partisan farce what they're
saying
anything you accuse trump of anything he
incited violence uh what
what happened for the past eight months
he trump incited violence he said be
peaceful before during and after the
riots meanwhile
you have maxine waters hillary clinton
kamala harris bailing out the rioters
for goodness sakes all of them
encouraging violence on their own side
you don't see them getting censured you
don't see them being removed or
impeached
it's a farce and it's backed up by
squishy republicans by court jester
conservatives like liz cheney
who spends much of her time
more of her time most of her time
perhaps as far as i can tell
attacking republicans rather than going
after
the democrats rand paul gets that i mean
that's a guy i don't agree with rand
paul on everything just as rand paul
says i don't agree with trump on
everything and yet
i think we should all be able to
recognize
you can say those you can say that look
i disagreed in many ways with how trump
handled
not just the past two months but
actually the way he handled the past
year
i think he mishandled coronavirus it was
not entirely his fault he was
faced with an unbelievable amount of
pressure but i i wish he had he had
cut it out sooner and turned on fouchy
sooner you know okay sure i got these
problems with him
doesn't mean i think we should banish
donald trump i think we got to defend
our guy i think the real threat is
coming at us
from the left rand paul understands that
sort of thing
some other republicans they seem not to
understand that one little bit
if if you think i'll go back to that
republican congressman for a second
if you think that this woman is kooky
and delusional and unfit for office take
a listen to some of the democrats
rashida talib a member of the squad
took to the house floor the other day to
discuss
the riot at the capitol that she was not
present for
and uh basically turned it into a
struggle session of the new york radical
women's group like something out of the
1970s
she just stood up there and cried
because of how scared she imagined
she could be on my very first day
of orientation i got my first death
threat
it was a serious one they took me aside
the fbi had to go
to the gentleman's home i didn't even
get sworn in yet
when someone wanted me dead for just
existing
more came later uglier more violent
one celebrating and writing the new
zealand massacre
and hoping that more would come another
mentioning my dear son adam
mentioning him by name each one
paralyzed me each time
so what happened on january 6th all i
could do was thank allah
that i wasn't here i felt overwhelming
relief
and i feel bad for alexandria so many of
my colleagues that were here
but as i saw it i thought to myself
thank god
i am not there i saw the images that
they didn't get to see until later
yeah they didn't get to see until later
because they weren't there either aoc
walks up and
just puts her hand on her back while
this lunatic woman is crying what is she
crying over
what is this woman who is supposed to be
a national leader
somewhat a statesman someone with a
composure
reason sort of
elevated or at least normal comportment
what is she crying over
she wasn't there aoc wasn't there either
by the way as we've discussed over the
past uh
couple weeks she was not in the capital
she was in a building down the street
the building was evacuated sure but the
riders were not there
rashida talib is hysterically crying
at the house floor because she has
received
death threats every
single person in public life especially
politics has received death threats
everyone she says she received death
threats because she was existing no
she is receiving death threats because
she's in politics and it's an ugly fact
of politics but
every single person who is in politics
gets death threats
but she got death threats against her
family every single
person who is in any way
even slightly prominent in politics gets
death threats that is part of the job
it's a sad part it's an unfortunate part
if you're not prepared for that if that
if that aspect of the job
if that danger and that unpleasant
interaction
is going to reduce you to a and
hysterical crying lunatic
then you should get out of the job
you're not fit for it compare her
because i think this actually was
genuine i think this woman genuinely is
unhinged
compared to somebody like aoc who i
think is basically as cold as they come
i think she's got ice water running
through her veins
compare her to aoc who then walks up so
this woman
blubbering and this very dishonorable
display
then aoc sees an opportunity and she
just walks up cool as a cucumber puts
her hand on her back poses for the
camera
you know i mean this woman man she is
she is spooky that but they're not
they're not the same she recognized an
opportunity here to get herself on
camera and aoc
never misses that at all they used to
say that the most dangerous place in man
in in washington rather was between
chuck schumer and a tv
camera i think aoc has taken that honor
but this is this is pathetic whatever
kooks there are in the republican party
ain't none of them as kooky as rashida
talib and aoc
if this is how people respond to to
routine adversity
in politics they they have no place in
congress
the reason i i bring any of this up and
the reason i'm even
referring over the shoulder to this
republican congressman that they took
off the committees is
everyone seems to think this is about
this woman her name is marjorie taylor
greene
everyone thinks they're just after her
and then once they get her it'll be all
over it's not they're not after her
she is a particularly kooky and
eccentric person so they're going after
her because she's easy to attack
they're after all of us okay
marjorie taylor green is just now an
easy target
virtually no one would have ever heard
her name if cnn and the democrats did
not make her
a big deal because they they want to
make republicans either defend her or
attack her either way they win
really i think the only way that
republicans can respond in a
in a prudent way to this sort of thing
is to do what the democrats would do in
the same situation
namely completely ignore the attacks and
just move on this woman is not
particularly consequential
she's a member of congress how many
names of of members of congress
can you rattle off like 10
hundreds of members how many could you
actually name
sort of inconsequential but it's not
just about her
it's it's not even just about trump it's
about all of us
and actually bill maher who is who is
wrong about so many things so powerfully
wrong
bill maher is every so often honest
about the left's actual aims
and bill more more or less admitted this
on his show
this is not just about one or two
eccentric people spouting off
crazy theories this is about
delegitimizing
half of the country the triumph of
democracy
as time magazine puts it is when half
the country
is suppressed ostracized no longer has a
voice you know ben is going to be
talking about the time magazine
article talking about how all the elites
manipulated the 2020 election
he's also going to be talking about the
biden administration
continuing to tamp down school reopening
so go check that out on his show
you know you've probably heard me talk
about our all-access membership
before but for those of you who have not
heard me talk about it it is our most
elite membership base here at the daily
wire our daily wire members receive
two not one but two leftist years
tumblers when they sign up
being an all-access member means that
they get to watch full coverage of all
daily wire shows
what's more they get to tune into the
exclusive all-access live
a show featuring all the different hosts
every single day where we uh
we get to chat with you all access
members one thing i really love about it
is
i get to hear your ideas if you are an
all access member chances are you follow
politics you've got pretty interesting
ideas
and so i get to steal them and put them
on my show it's really helpful today we
want to publicly thank all of our all
access members for their commitment to
the daily wire
to show our appreciation we are going to
be mailing out a special
anniversary tumbler for all renewing all
access members this year
voila this on the front you see you've
got the classic leftist tears hot or
cold
daily wire on the back you get all of
our john hancocks
me ben drew matt jeremy
uh plus a short statement about our
belief that america's best days
are still ahead of us this is a
commemorative piece
to our five-year journey and thank you
to all of our all-access members in
particular
for supporting what we're doing here so
thank you very much
cheers guzzle the tears we'll be right
back with a lot more
democrats want us to believe
that they're just after that congress
lady
or they're just after trump or they're
just after i don't know there's always
someone they seem to be just after just
one more person and then they'll respect
us then they'll like us right
bill maher who is occasionally honest
often wrong but occasionally honest has
admitted
this isn't about trump or
marjorie greene or or conspiracy
theories it's about
all of us it's about conservatives it's
about christians
it's about people who hold traditional
beliefs in this country
the left thinks we're all the same the
left thinks there's no difference
i've mentioned this on the show you
notice how they don't say alt-right
anymore
the alt-right whatever that at one point
i think it did have a real meaning but
now it doesn't really have any meaning
at all
they don't care about the alt-right or
they're this right or the conservatives
or they just think we're all the same
bill maher
they just think we're all the same and
they think we're all completely in
lunatics or right completely insane and
they
they want us ostracized from society as
long as we're going to
go to the trouble of another impeachment
trial we might as well be honest about
what it's really about
the events of january 6th were a
faith-based initiative
and trumpism is a christian nationalist
movement
that believes trump was literally sent
from heaven to save them
it's right there in senator tommy
tuberville's campaign ad
god sent us donald trump because god
knew we were in trouble
there's a lot of talk now in liberal
quarters about how republicans should
tell their base who still believe the
election was rigged
that they need to grow up and move on
and stop asking the rest of us to
respect their mass delusion
and of course it is a mass delusion but
the inconvenient truth here is that if
you record religious faith
the kind of exalted respect we do here
in america
you've already lost the argument that
mass delusion is bad
it's fun to laugh at q anon with the
baby eating lizard people and the
pedophile pizza parlors but
have you ever read the book of
revelations
uh because bill maher probably hasn't
read the book of revelations because
the book of revelation is not called the
book of revelations the dude couldn't
even get the name of the book right
as he's making fun of it which is true
of so many of these sophomoric
atheist types i mean i think i think the
days of the bill maher style
atheism are over there was this kind of
publishing fad in the mid 2000s
they called him the new atheists it was
like christopher hitchens daniel dennett
richard dawkins sam harris
and their books i read some of their
books uh were very
weak and they didn't even make the
arguments they were purporting to make
but you know it was popular among like
14 year old boys
in urban areas or something and uh it
wasn't
to be really taken seriously and bill
maher is not to be taken seriously right
he doesn't
he he exposes the biblical literacy and
theological
insight of most of these people he
doesn't even know the name of the book
but he is espousing the view i think of
many leftists namely
if you believe that there is something
more to this world than just
physical matter that uh you know
beyond the the tumbler and the desk and
the microphone and my
body if you believe that our in our
bodies we're not just meat puppets but
we actually have
souls or we have mind we have
loves dreams other ideas there's
mathematics right things that are
metaphysical they're not just physical
that you're kind of kooky now of course
if you put it in those terms to them
they would say no i don't deny math i
don't deny dreams i don't deny ideas but
they
they do they just aren't philosophically
sophisticated enough to
talk about it you know you sort of you
can imagine thomas aquinas looking down
from heaven now saying oh darn i got
owned by bill maher
i never re i never realized that it's
foolish
to believe in the book of revelations
darn totally owned by that
hack comedian i thomas aquinas one of
the
most brilliant people to ever walk the
earth this is what they believe now
you heard that phrase in there that bill
maher mentioned christian nationalism
what is christian nationalism what does
that mean it's a phrase that's become
popular
these these slogans spread like memes
and the left has been pushing this one
recently
i guess christian nationalism means the
belief that we are a nation
and a christian nation at that which is
obviously true the united states is a
christian nation
there is some complexity to that because
it's a christian nation that has broad
toleration among the protestant
denominations and even had toleration
for catholics
and even from the founding era had
toleration for jews
and didn't totally love muslims because
obviously the early americans were being
uh
kidnapped and killed by barbary pirates
that was our first war after we had
gained independence so that complicated
things but you know generally then we
kind of expanded tolerance
to some muslims too and okay so it's
it's all of that is
complex history is much more complex
than slogans
but while all of that is true it is also
the case that we are a christian nation
we were founded by christian
zealots who who took a ship over here
from england called the mayflower
and founded a puritanical colony
later puritans who arrived referred to
this as a shining city upon a hill
we had established churches in this
country
well past the founding era our our
document
our founding document the declaration of
independence refers
to the philosophical basis of this
country as the natural rights that
we are endowed with by our creator what
was their vision of a creator well go
back and read their writings
their vision of a creator was at least
broadly speaking
a christian god well of course they were
steeped in the christian culture
it's not it's not a hindu country it's
not a muslim country
it wasn't a jewish country and it wasn't
a
a pagan country right it wasn't
a secular atheist country which i guess
you'd say now the dominant religion in
the country is secular
liberalism or you know sort of atheism i
guess
or some kind of weird paganism with all
the crystals and the horoscopes and all
the wacky stuff that liberals believe
now
but certainly thomas even thomas
jefferson was pretty radical didn't
believe that
john adams didn't believe that george
washington didn't believe that
so what what bill moore is saying is
these awful terrible people
they believe in the vision of america as
it existed from 1620 until like five
minutes ago
but that's bad that's evil that's wicked
that needs to be ostracized
because we on the left want to upend
society we want to overturn that
tradition
and implement our radical designs
at least he's honest at least he's
honest i think that's true of most
most left-wingers believe that sort of
thing but they aren't willing to admit
it
the reality of what the left believes
about us
is pretty spooky there was a doctor who
just got in some trouble
because he uh he had some pretty
negative things to say about
his country and about his countrymen dr
cleven gilman
uh had a video going around regarding
people in florida not wearing masks he
said naples florida
let them die i'm so tired of these
people
no vaccine for y'all okay now you might
say
this doctor he was just kidding he was
letting off steam he was being
intentionally provocative
he didn't really mean that well he got a
lot of blow back
and so he apologized sort of he said
republicans trying to take my words out
of context as if i deny medical care to
people that we're
that don't wear masks and let them die
okay well good yeah i guess we did think
that because that's what you said you
were
going to do so i'm glad you're saying
i'm not really going to do that then he
goes on he says
my point is that we can't waste our
energy on these covid deniers
they are not going to protect themselves
so let them die they'll find out the
hard way
wait what hold on you just said you
didn't
so you said that's what you believe and
then you said that was taken out of
context and you don't believe that and
then one sentence later you said but
that actually is what i believe
and this guy is he's not just some
random doctor mouthing off i mean first
of all you'd expect more from any doctor
these are supposed to be
elevated people who've gone to a lot of
schooling who have a bedside manner who
are
sacrificing themselves this guy is
prominent enough
that joe biden gave him a call on the
campaign trail and they filmed an ad
together
[Music]
hello hey dr gilman this is joe biden i
just called a thank you for your service
you're an iraqi war veteran you know i
understand that you're going to do
whatever it takes to get this pandemic
under control and i just want you to
know how much i appreciate what you and
so many others like you are doing
risking your rear ends
and going out of your way to help other
people thanks a lot sir you know what i
grew up
with a special impediment and i did not
really have a whole lot of opportunities
until i joined the military i've been
very fortunate to have come home once
escaped i was in
new york on the front lines whereas i
lost three of my colleagues out there
i lost my 27
year old cousin who was really healthy
who was trying out for the nfl
i'm really looking forward to
you becoming president sir i'm going to
do everything in my power and i promise
you doc
you're gonna have a full-blown partner
you have my word as a bite all right so
you have a great day
now in joe's defense my word is a biden
and a buck 50 will get you a cup of
coffee so
uh so that that at least is a little bit
of comfort
but i don't like the idea that gilman's
going to have a full
full partner in joe biden is gilman is
saying
that he wants conservatives to die
he doesn't just want them to lose
elections want us to lose elections
he doesn't just want us to shut up
he wants us to die he said that
then he said he didn't say that but then
he said it again
the very next sentence
the left is not going to turn on this
guy the left is not going to turn in
just like they didn't turn on maxine
waters or hillary clinton
or eric holder or cory booker
or kamala harris or any of these people
who
have actively encouraged violence
against conservatives
i'm beginning to get the impression that
they don't like
us and any political strategy look
politics changes by circumstance
there are eternal principles but we
apply those principles through the light
of
received opinion and tradition to
changing circumstances
and where once it may have been a
prudent strategy
to try to make nice and be conciliatory
with democrats and come together in
kumbaya
your your opponents get a say in
politics just like your enemies get a
say in war
and if if they don't like us if they
don't want to work with us at all
and we we can't force it we're only
going to hurt ourselves if we force it
two different strategies you know liz
cheney saying that uh
trump has no role in the future of the
republican party who do you think
better represents the republican party
right now donald trump
and people of like mind
or liz cheney and people of
of her like mind which one do you think
trump or cheney who would you if
election were held today who would you
vote for i
i don't think it would be close
the hypocrisy is the double standard
rather
is i think what's showing this to people
you get this
doctor you get all this kind of violent
rhetoric you get antifa marching through
the streets of dc
just the other day with black lives
matter
chanting that they wanted to burn it
down take a listen
a little hard to hear it and we had to
bleep out every other word and that's
the most peaceful video i could find a
lot of the other videos are involving
real clashes between
police uh antifa protesters
uh threatened to burn down washington dc
during the quote
dc queer and trans black history month
march and rally
pause for a second obviously i don't
keep up with the uh
liturgical calendar of liberalism too
much
i'm i'm still looking at the sort of old
catholic liturgical calendar you know
uh but so i knew though that february
was black history month turns out it's
no longer just black history month
it's a queer and trans black history
month so i don't know when
sort of ordinary black people get their
own history month but this has gotten
very very specific
the direct quote from the antifa people
was if we don't get it burn it down
so this is a violent insurrection in
washington dc
much more violent than what happened at
the capitol just as the blm
riots over the summer in dc were much
more violent than
anything that happened at the capitol
and
everyone condemns the capital fair
enough that makes perfect sense to me
yeah i think riots are very bad
nobody nobody except for some
republicans some conservatives
condemn this kind of stuff in dc
the the tough republicans condemn this
stuff in dc
the squishy republicans not so much
complete double standard here complete
double standard and it it does come out
of a sort of
new caste system a racial and sexual
caste system
that the left is trying to push i mean
that you know you see it even in the way
they name the months right it goes from
black history month
to queer and trans black history month
they're just getting
more and more narrow on more and more
victim groups and the idea of course is
that your
your value comes from the amount of
grievance and suffering that you can
claim and that value translates to
certain privileges
if certain protected groups be they
sexual racial or political
get you know commit certain acts commit
violence in the streets
they will not be punished in the same
way that disfavored groups
on sexual racial and political lines do
you could say it's hypocrisy or it's a
double standard sure it's really just a
hierarchy as i think adrian vermeule the
law professor
makes this distinction hierarchy versus
hypocrisy
the the liberal regime just has a new
hierarchy and and the left is explicitly
trying to push this
you may remember some months ago nick
cannon
got cancelled he got semi-cancelled
because he made comments about
white people broadly and jews
specifically
and they were pretty pretty vicious
comments so
he had lost some of his contracts he got
in a little bit of trouble according to
the hollywood reporter
viacom cbs has resumed its professional
relationship with nick cannon
will allow nick cannon to get his job
back and resume production on his very
same vh1 series
wild and out uh viacom says quote
nick has not only apologized and taken
responsibility for his comments but he
has also worked to educate himself and
others through engagement with jewish
leaders and on his platforms
those efforts are of the most utmost
importance and that's why we have
invited him to rejoin our team on a
separate note we just learned that he
tested positive for kovid
and we wish it was speedy recovery uh
okay what does the covet thing have to
do with anything
so a few levels to this here first of
all
if this were reversed
and if the people that nick cannon
attacked
had made any kind of racial comments in
the other direction
they would not be given a second chance
they would not be given probably any
work in the future
much less their job back it just
wouldn't happen
that is a special privilege that nick
cannon has received
that disfavored groups would not receive
but there's another level here so i'm
glad to see that nick cannon
has apologized for his comments about
jews and he went to the holocaust
memorial
and he sort of did a few performative
acts to say he he regrets his comments
about jews
that's good but he's not he's never
apologized for his vicious comments
against white people
generally in case you had forgotten take
a listen
melanin comes with compassion melanin
comes with soul that we call it we call
it soul we
soul brothers and sisters that's the
melon in that connection so the people
that don't have it
have are are a lit and i'm going to say
this carefully
are a little less and
and and where the term actually comes
from because i'm bringing it all the way
back around okay
to minister farrakhan the only way that
they can act is
evil the only way they can they they
have to rob steal
rape kill and fight the flight or in
order to survive
exactly so then these people who didn't
have what we had
and when i say we i speak of the
melanated people
right they had to be savages they had
to be barbaric they had because they're
in these nordic mountains they're in
these
rough uh torrential environments
so they they're acting as animals right
so they're the ones that are
actually closer to animals white people
you see
actually closer to animals they're less
than they're they're
savages because they don't have souls
it's become sort of trite even to do
this whole thing of well if the roles
were reversed could you imagine
just imagine though for a second ryan
seacrest
you know he's doing his podcast and he's
got some guests on it he says
you see the thing about melanated
peoples is they're animals and savages
and they don't have souls
i'm talking about black people you see
yes no you understand and then have the
person there he says yes no i
totally agree and then ryan seacrest
goes on he says yeah you know they're
less than
and that's why they behave like animals
of course you know this sort of thing
would never happen if it did
i think ryan seacrest would be sent to
guantanamo bay for saying something like
this right
but nick cannon gets away with this
never apologizes for it right he
apologizes for very specific comments
but doesn't apologize for these broader
comments
and he gets his job back do you think
that's a fair system do you think that's
a system for
racial equity uh tolerance unity and
healing
no absolutely not it's a vicious vile
caste system
that deplores some people on the basis
of race
and sex by the way and religion as bill
maher showed and all these sorts of
things
and gives other people special
privileges
do we want to live under that system
does anybody want to live under that
system i don't think
so mass delusion
my friends there was a uh
a monument that just went up at the
lincoln memorial so there's obviously
the lincoln memorial's monument there's
another monument that just went up
to vice president kamala harris what has
kamala harris done
nothing why did they
put it up well because she's the first
woman of color elected to the nation's
second highest office
and so it's a memorial and not a
memorial she's still alive it's a
monument
that's that's got some shattered glass
on it you get it so subtle
shattered the glass ceiling now she's
not the first person of color to serve
as vice president that was
actually herbert hoover's vice president
almost 100 years ago
but this portrait is up there now it
shows that the left does not view kamala
harris as a person they view her as a
type
just like they view all people as types
you're your race or you're your sex or
you're what but you're not
an individual and speaking of bad art i
can't the only thing i want to say about
the super bowl
other than tom brady very impressive
great stuff uh the only thing i want to
say is
amanda gorman amanda gorman is that slam
poet
slam poe test that spoke at the
inauguration that we we went over on
this show
uh this is the first super bowl
thankfully i didn't watch it but it's
the first super bowl i've ever heard of
that had a slam poetry section to it
and they chose for the slam poem
the now famous inaugurals poetess
amanda gorman take a listen
today we honor our three captains
for their actions and impact in a time
of
uncertainty and need they've taken
the lead exceeding all expectations and
limitations
uplifting their communities and
neighbors as
leaders healers and educators
james has felt the wounds of warfare but
this warrior still
shares his home with at-risk kids
during covet he's even lent a hand live
streaming football
for family and fans tremaine is an
educator who works
non-stop providing his community with
hot spots
laptops and tech workshops so his
students have
all the tools they need to succeed in
life
and in school susie is the icu nurse
manager
at a tampa hospital her chronicles prove
that even in tragedy hope is possible
she lost her grandmothers
to the pandemic and fights to save other
lives in the icu
battle zone defining the frontline
heroes risking their lives
for our own i can't i can't take any
more i uh harold bloom called slam
poetry the death of art
absolutely that is true we have
mass delusion all around this country
right now
if anyone believes that the audience of
the super bowl wants to listen to some
politically correct woke slam poem
goodness gracious we are our problems of
delusion they go a lot deeper than some
random congressmen
when or when will we get our senses back
if we keep listening to that sort of
stuff not anytime soon i'm michael knows
this the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
board
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show
you